do you want to know how to fly first
class
for free so a flight attendant broke
down one simple trick
that can get you into first class no
questions as here it is she says when
you check in
the people checking you will literally
mark you down as suitable for an upgrade
if you look nice and only if you look
nice the trick is that you need to look
nice on every single flight if you look
like trash be prepared to sit in the
back you ain't getting an upgrade
okay go back to a story don't be stinky
don't be stinking rule number five there
it is rule number five
so yeah so the flight attendant is like
look here's the deal so basically here's
this deal
so we all know that traveling first
class means the good stuff give me the
good stuff right you get a comfortable
seat you get to lie down you get the
good stuff going on you get the good
service you get the hot towel you get
the glass of wine you get the champagne
you get the tasty food you're living the
good life
um
so
this girl she posts something on tick
tock her name is sierra kirkpatrick she
posted a video on tick tock and she
asked her friend who's a flight
attendant she goes listen what are the
tips what are the tricks give me the low
down give me the good stuff give me that
insider scoop she said
i want to know what i got to do in order
to get to you know the first class she
goes listen uh that's what you need to
do you need to look nice on every single
flight now apparently they they
literally mark you down as suitable for
an upgrade that's funny and they judge
you on how you look you know i don't
like to be judged i don't like to be
judged
people are judging you baby you you and
i on a flight would get split up
i'm looking good david go sit in the
bathroom yeah um so you know if you get
if you look like a piece of garbage
you're never going to get upgraded it's
basically what they're saying
together yeah exactly so if you're just
rocking you know because people
you know if you're rocking sweatpants
you're you know a hoodie you're a girl
you just got your hair up in a bun like
you're doing nothing
you're probably not going to cut it back
in the day you ever seen these images of
how people used to fly
three-piece suits a top hat a fancy
dress keep in mind you are smoking
cigarettes the whole flight yeah things
are a little backwards now people don't
know how to act on flights people are
going insane mass mandates vaccines who
knows what's going on people haven't
traveled in two years they get on a
flight that
they're insane there's a flight that
there was a just a story the other day
about a flight from canada went to
cancun they were literally popping
bottles busting out the dj like like
partying on the plane it went viral it
was a it was a
private jet not a private jet but like
uh like a
not a commercial thing okay
chartered thank you all right
19 episodes the charter flight boom
and they
the airline canceled their tickets
they're like you can't come back like
the based on your behavior these videos
like good luck getting back oh no way
straight up people are fist fighting on
flights
people are acting like trash looking
like trash acting like trash you know
what's you buy trash what's your flight
attire kind of what you got going on now
i like wearing
jeans and a nice shirt okay sometimes if
i travel i wear a jacket i'll i'll be
honest pants
yeah i mean i don't i mean i'm bored
based on based on this
information will you start dressing a
little bit nicer depends where i'm going
depends when you're going well here i'm
thinking like an international flight
yeah so they'll say here it is here it
is here's the kicker here's the kicker
here's the kicker you know it says
though sometimes they'll upgrade you
regardless of status even if you've
never flown this airline just because
you look nice but note the trick is this
mostly works for international flights
on international airlines not
necessarily domestic yeah flights within
the united states i feel like that's
like the
by the way upgrades are now only
conditional for the international
flights not constantly if you wear a
hammer
speaking this is your pilot speaking you
look like trash go sit in the back
let me hear a good pilot
uh ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain speaking to the person bro beef
you can sit three rows back thank you
very much you're kind of grossing me out
exactly
so what's a takeaway here look good
don't stink
don't be gross
dress to impress whether it's a job
interview whether it's a flight
people are going to judge you that's
going to be the name of this episode
don't be stinky don't be stinky dress to
impress dress for the job you want dress
for the potential upgrade
people appreciate it clearly people they
if this is real that they
look at your attire and they say
suitable for an upgrade yeah not
suitable for an upgrade yeah this dude
stank
you know you're not gonna get that
upgrade yeah um so anyways look your
best feel your best act your best do
your best that's that um how shitty
though that you dress up your nicest and
your finest threads and then they're
like
and you're just waiting for that would
you like to upgrade and they don't it's
just awkward because you know they
should because you look good but you
stay like damn i this is the best i can
do this is all i got is that enough
anyway that's a little money move of the
week hope you can save that money fly
first class cause you looking good
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken